- I AM AT PEACE.
MY WILL IS FREE.
- [whistling]
- I AM AT PEACE.
- [screeches]
KYLE!
- ADAM?
- KYLE, I'M FREAKING OUT.
- ADAM, WHAT?
- I'M FREAKING OUT, DUDE.
- WHAT IS ALL OVER YOU?
- I KILLED A GUY!
- WHAT?
- I JUST KILLED A GUY, MAN.
IT WAS JUST--ALL OF A SUDDEN,
HE WAS JUST THERE,
AND HE WASN'T DEAD;
THEN I WAS LIKE, "HE'S DEAD!"
- ARE YOU SURE IT WAS A MAN?
- IT WAS A MAN!
DEFINITELY A MAN,
HE HAD LONG HAIR,
BUT IT WAS DEFINITELY A MAN.
- OKAY, OKAY, OKAY, CALM DOWN.
WE NEED YOU, BUDDY.
THE FIRST THING WE NEED
YOU TO DO IS
GET OUT OF THESE CLOTHES, OKAY?
THE COMICS ARE GONNA BE HERE
ANY MINUTE, SO GET OUT OF THEM,
OR ELSE THEY'RE GONNA KNOW.
GO UPSTAIRS.
DON'T SMACK ME, OKAY?
I'LL START THINKING
OF AN ALIBI,
AND THEN I'LL TIE UP
ALL THE LOOSE ENDS, OKAY?
I GOT YOUR BACK, MAN.
ALL RIGHT, BROTHER.
- YOU'RE MY HETERO BROTHER
FROM A DIFFERENT MOTHER.
- I HAVE YOUR BACK,
JUST LIKE A BROTHER.
- GOT YOUR BACK.
- I'LL FREAKING FOLLOW YOU
TO THE END.
- THANK YOU
FOR HELPING ME.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
GET OUT OF HERE.
I'LL TAKE CARE OF IT.
- I FREAKING LOVE YOU, DUDE.
- ALL RIGHT, BROTHER.
HELLO, THE POLICE?
YEAH, I'D LIKE
TO REPORT A MURDER.
YEAH, UNFORTUNATELY MY FRIEND,
ADAM DEVINE, KILLED SOMEONE.
[theme music plays]